[Music]
it's the month of june and as always
there's a lot of buzz in the air about a
possible nintendo direct happening soon
now i'm not gonna try and predict if and
when it'll happen or what the lineup
will be if it does because honestly i'd
have a better chance trying to predict
an earthquake i mean who knows it may
have already been announced by the time
this video goes up taking chances here
people taking chances whatever the case
may be the mere possibility of a direct
brings with it the same burning question
we've had for pretty much every nintendo
showcase taking place since 2019 will we
see more of breath the wild 2 not
counting the delay announcement back in
march which let's be fair only showed
about 7 seconds of new footage the last
big news update we got on the game is
now a full year ago since my dad doesn't
work at nintendo i can't say for sure if
the game will show up all i can say is
if there's any time to get excited for
zelda news there's no time like the
present as the month of june and zelda
have historically been best friends so
with that said for this video i thought
it would be fun to go through the entire
timeline of breath well 2's development
cycle chronologically from the very
beginning since even before we knew
about the sequel all the way up to the
present day we'll talk about all the
news every update everything we've
gotten so far as well as discuss some of
the most talked about rumors leaks and
theories while we're at it by the end
you'll be completely up to speed on the
game's progress the facts and what to
expect from future news if the game does
decide to show up so let's get right
into it it's february 14 2017 and breath
of the wild is looming on the horizon
but there's no rest for the wicked
because before the game even hits store
shelves aonuma steps forward and
announces additional content for the
game an expansion pass and two dlc packs
which would be distributed between
release day and december of that same
year it would be the first time ever
that a mainline zelda game would receive
downloadable content so what does this
have to do with the sequel well jumping
forward a bit to june 18 2019 seven days
after the sequel's review at e3 producer
aj onuma explains in an interview with
kotaku that breath the wall 2 was
initially part of a series of ideas
meant for dlc but that it grew beyond
the scope of something a dlc pack could
handle it's hard to pinpoint the exact
moment the decision was made to turn the
dlc concept into a proper sequel but it
had to have been somewhere between the
launch of breath to wild and the second
dlc pack we know for a fact that the
zelda team was planning to make at least
one more dlc pack on top of the two we
ended up getting maybe even more than
that anuma explains that he wanted to do
more than just add new data to the base
game and so he opted to take the game's
engine and core assets and start from
scratch his choice of words of wanting
to start from scratch implies that the
sequel was always meant to be more than
just a simple asset flip with some new
enemies and dungeons thrown in there
which is a concern many fans have had
since the beginning anyway back to 2017.
on april the 4th one month after the
release of breath the wild the series
producer states in an interview with
famitsu that moving forward the open air
concept will likely be a standard for
zelda in the future which is not
necessarily a reference to breathtak 2
specifically as it's not clear if the
decision to start working on a sequel
was already made at this stage i'd say
probably not but for those who worry if
the sequel will have the same open
nature as its predecessor there you go
on june 30 2017 dlc pack 1 would become
available for download on both wii u and
switch and 5 months later on the 8th of
december aj onuma revealed dlc pack 2
the champion's ballot in front of a live
audience at the annual game awards which
became available for download that same
day it's all but confirmed that by this
point the sequel's development had
officially kicked off behind the scenes
because not even nine days later
masterworks was published a book solely
devoted to the lore and development
history of breath of the wild and it's
here on the final pages that aonuma
himself reveals for the very first time
that the next zelda game is officially
in the works of course this was the
japanese edition so for most fans
outside of japan this wouldn't become a
well-known fact until the book was
localized at the end of 2018. speaking
of 2018 it was a quiet year for zelda
news and many were still enjoying breath
the wild in its dlc the only small
revelation we got was on the 6th of
november when ign reported on a series
of job listings popping up on nintendo
of japan's official website gaming
journalists had no idea what to make of
this at the time because nobody knew
what kind of zelda projects were in the
works nintendo's president shanturo
furukawa had recently stated that he
wanted to see even more dlc for breath
the wild and there were even some rumors
about a zelda game for mobile floating
around despite our numa's statement that
a new game was in development it wasn't
a known fact that this would be a direct
sequel to breath the wild and other
zelda projects like link's awakening for
switch and skyward sword hd were also
still under wraps of course the job
offers have since been removed from the
company's website as the positions would
have been taken a long time ago but the
article from ign still exists it was
allegedly a request for level designers
who have experience in designing terrain
fields enemies and dungeons in hindsight
it's obvious that the job listings were
indeed connected to breathtak 2. skyward
sword hd probably wasn't even in
development yet and doesn't feature new
dungeons enemies or terrain and link's
awakening was being developed by grezzo
which is a third party lastly on
november 20th the english edition of
masterworks aptly named creating a
champion released in europe and north
america and that wraps up 2018 in 2019
zelda news started picking up link's
awakening for switch was announced at
the usual february direct and on june 11
the cat was finally out of the bag
nintendo's e3 presentation had already
achieved legendary status with the
review of banjo kazooie as the next
fighter for smash but in what is perhaps
one of the biggest mic drops in gaming
history they closed out the show by
revealing the sequel to the critically
acclaimed breath of the wild the one and
a half minute story teaser sees the hero
and princess exploring a dark cavern
accompanied by a very haunting music
score around the half-minute mark we get
a few close-ups of an ominous
corpse-like figure who based on his
attire and the music cue that plays is
widely accepted to be none other than
ganondorf back in his human form this
time as opposed to the silent spectre we
saw in the previous game additionally a
mysterious green arm is seen latched
onto the demon king's chest and while
there's no shortage of theories about it
nobody truly knows who or what this
being is after a series of quick edits
in which we see the hero's arm being
possessed by some sort of green energy
the demon king's corpse is seen
springing to life accompanied by a neck
snap that would make even the most
seasoned chiropractor uncomfortable we
then cut to a shot of hyrule castle
seemingly starting to rise up from the
ground followed by a message that
confirms that the sequel to breath of
the wild is now in development no title
no release date no additional info
suffice to say that every single shot of
this teaser has been scrutinized and
analyzed to death by now including by
yours truly so i'm not going to go into
further detail here if you want to know
more about the possible story details
there's a wide array of analysis and
theory videos for you to enjoy all with
vastly different takes and ideas one
thing that is worth mentioning is that
around this time people started
discovering a lot of parallels between
some of the teaser footage and concept
art included in masterworks particularly
the one where link's arm is either
damaged or mutated or transforming into
all sorts of weapons and tools it was
speculated that whatever was happening
to link's arm could serve as the basis
for all kinds of new powers and
abilities especially since the sheikah
slate is nowhere to be seen in the
coming days from june 11 to 18 onuma
took part in a series of interviews in
which he would answer a few burning
questions and reveal some additional
tidbits of information albeit not much
while talking to ign on the show floor
of e3 he mostly stuck to the subject of
link's awakening which was set to
release in september but he did share a
few things about the sequel because of
the darker tone of the footage and the
fact that it's a direct sequel ign asked
if the game was perhaps inspired by
majira's mask the sequel to ocarina of
time and considered to be one of the
darkest entries in the series to which
anuma responded that the game will not
necessarily be related to or inspired by
majira's mask and that it just so
happens that what they showed in the
teaser was a bit darker this quote
quickly spread around like wildfire and
was used as proof that the game would be
even darker than the n64 classic however
many have since spoken up against this
presumption suggesting that it's a
misinterpretation of anuma's words and i
agree the phrase what we showed you
currently is a little bit darker is
clearly a general statement about the
nature of the teaser itself and not in
reference to majira's mask that isn't to
say that the game won't have its fair
share of darker elements though i mean
the stuff we see here is definitely more
eerie and foreboding than anything we
saw in breath the wild seeing as link
and zelda are seen exploring the cave
together ign also wondered if we might
see some sort of co-op between the two
which the series producer in classic
enuma fashion either confirms nor denies
it seems to lean more towards denial
though as he remarks that in the
previous game the two were also seen
together a lot of the time and thus he
finds it interesting that people would
go straight into the thought of co-op
however i can't speak for the man
obviously so until we see more it'll
remain a what-if scenario the final
revelation in this interview is that
allegedly some of the zelda staff had
been playing red dead redemption 2 which
came out one and a half years after
breath the wild this led many to
speculate that breathtak 2 may have
taken some inspiration from red that too
the same way skyrim inspired the
original but if that's true and what
these possible inspirations might be
remains to be seen the next day on june
12 he sat down with game informer he
said that one of the reasons for
choosing a direct sequel was that he
wanted to visit that same hyrule again
confirming that the events would indeed
be taking place in the same world as its
predecessor he goes on to mention that
he's grown fond of the idea of dlc and
that going forward he'll be thinking
about doing it again so there's a very
good chance that breathtog2 will receive
downloadable content down the line as
well finally he confirms that for the
sequel director hiramaru fujibayashi is
returning again for the same role and a
few days later on june 18 he would have
the interview with kotaku we talked
about earlier where he reveals that
breath 202 started out as dlc on july
5th 2019 another set of job listings was
posted to nintendo's website which again
pertained to level design with an
emphasis on dungeons like before these
are no longer present on the website
itself but an article by gamesradar
covering the topic does still exist and
that rounds up 2019 at least when it
comes to news about the sequel link's
awakening released on the 20th of
september however no further comments
were made on breathtawa 2 by any of the
staff and so we were left waiting for
the next major update little did we know
that we were about to enter what came to
be known as the great nintendo drought
of 2020
[Music]
as the pandemic took the world by
surprise nintendo news in general would
slow down to an absolute crawl the
second and third quarter were
particularly barren for switch owners
many pointed out that the japanese work
culture isn't exactly well adapted to
working remotely and so it's all but
certain that breathtaking's development
suffered some significant slowdown
during this period and it shows because
for the next 18 months there were no
major updates to the game at all no new
footage no release date no title nothing
on july 6 there was a short-lived
controversy regarding two spanish voice
actors which gave fans a shimmer of hope
that maybe the game was in a much
further state of development than
originally thought and could show up
again soon after all it was reported
that on a local podcast the voice actors
for rivali and zelda said that they were
done working on the spanish dub of the
game in the industry it's common
knowledge that the localization takes
place in the final stages of development
and means that the animations dialogue
and thus the story have all been
finalized however these reports would
later be corrected or retracted
altogether as it became clear that there
was a lot of nuance and context missing
from the language used and knowing what
we know now this was indeed a classic
case of fake news the only official
update we got this year came in
september when hyrule warrior's age of
calamity was unexpectedly announced on
twitter prior to showing the new
warriors title aonuma briefly took the
stage to announce that in regards to the
sequel to breath wild the team was
working hard on it and that we'd have to
wait a bit longer so basically the
update was that there are no updates
with the release of age of calamity only
two and a half months later the train
wreck that was 2020 came to a close and
luckily 2021 would prove to be a lot
more fruitful in terms of zelda news it
immediately started out strong in the
first general nintendo direct since late
2019 aonuma stepped forward in a similar
fashion to announce skyward sword hd
which had been rumored since 2016 but
never confirmed until now for those who
hoped to see more of breathtawa 2
however the announcement was bittersweet
as once again the only update we got was
that they didn't have anything to show
right now and that we'd have to wait
just a little bit longer a little bit
longer turned out to be four months
however unbeknownst to us nintendo had
issued a series of gameplay patents
attributed to breathtak 2 between may 24
and 26 about two weeks before e3 but
these patents wouldn't become public
until december so i'll skip the details
for now finally on june 15 we got the
long-awaited second look at the sequel
to breath of the wild and what it showed
was a little different than last time it
does start out with a similar dark and
eerie atmosphere with a brief flash of
link's arm being devoured by malice
ganondorf's corpse during the ymca
followed by a tragic image of zelda
disappearing into a chasm her fate's
still unknown even today but what
follows is a lot more buoyant and unlike
last time there's actual gameplay
footage present for the first time it's
revealed that the skies above hyrule
will be part of a new explorable space
with these beautiful islands floating
high above the surface the paraglider is
back once again which was already kind
of a no-brainer we see a few new and
repurposed enemy types a strange robot
creature we haven't seen before and we
also got solid confirmation that indeed
link's right arm has been affected and
will serve as a gameplay feature we see
a few new abilities in action like some
sort of time reversal as well as an
interesting mechanic that sees link
phasing through a ceiling and onto a
floor above the teaser comes to a close
with a shot of the castle seemingly
floating in place as we hear zelda's
lullaby being played in the background
and after a fade to black we see 2022
fading into view giving us the first
estimate of a release date albeit a very
broad one all in all it was amazing to
see the game on display after all this
time however it was still just a teaser
once again with a run time of only about
90 seconds similar to the first one we
were also still left without a title
which was a bit unusual for a game set
to release in one year or so but hey
after the barren wasteland that was 2020
we were happy enough to see anything at
this point with the game having finally
resurfaced many were hoping that the
floodgates were now wide open however
this would unfortunately prove not to be
the case in the days following the e3
presentation onuma himself would remain
absent instead bill trinin from nintendo
treehouse live would be the one to
elaborate on the game further in an
interview with ign on june 17 the
correlation between breath to wall 2 and
majora's mask would be brought up again
to which bill responded that although
the comparisons are understandable he
assures that it really is its own game
as players will come to find out i
understand people making that conclusion
but
i think that by the time you're you
finish playing it i think everybody's
probably going to come to the conclusion
that this is really sort of it's it's
its own thing he was also asked about
potential time travel a question which
he expertly dodged without confirming or
denying anything all um interesting
observations you know it's amazing the
degree to which people will analyze the
trailers and look at sort of every frame
the big news for us is is just letting
people dig into that and kind of guess
what they can and you'll get more
information on some of those details as
we get closer to when it launches in
2022. he goes on to explain why the
title of the game has been kept a secret
so far stating that revealing it now
could potentially give too much of the
story away prematurely so for now
they're sticking with the sequel to
breath the wild placeholder i don't know
what that means for the title i mean
most of the series titles don't exactly
give away key plot elements but i guess
we'll find out sooner or later he also
hinted that we would see more of the
game in the coming months or so and into
the next year which didn't exactly
tamper expectations so uh bill you're a
phony
hey this guy's a great big phony come on
chris the only new information we'd see
before the end of the year were the
patents i mentioned earlier which became
available for the public to see on
december the 2nd they outlined three
major gameplay mechanics all of which
were seen in action to some degree in
the latest teaser hence why they were
issued in the weeks before it covers the
time reversal ability the phasing
mechanic where link moves through solid
matter and the last one covers the type
of maneuverability link will have in
free fall instead of explaining it all
here i can recommend checking out these
videos i made which i will link in the
description below the patents are
surprisingly deep and each video
explains them in full detail with custom
animations to visualize how it all works
ending shameless plug now thus we enter
2022 which in case you got your
calendars mixed up is the year we find
ourselves in today and what better way
to start off a new year full of
potential and possibilities than with
yep not even a quarter of the way into
the new year and nintendo shadow drops a
video in which anuma has to explain that
2022 is no longer on the table yay
disappointing for sure but fortunately
it's not all bad news because in terms
of expectations anuma shared an amazing
detail about the game namely that the
expanded world goes beyond that of the
surface and the sky we've seen so far
and that there will be an even wide
array of features and mechanics to enjoy
including new encounters and gameplay
elements on top of that we at least have
a more accurate launch window now
instead of just a year we now have a
season to look forward to spring 2023 of
course the most striking part of the
delay video is that they unexpectedly
shoved some new footage in between the
stuff we had already seen it's not much
but what it does show is a pretty big
deal many had been wondering what
happened to the master sword seeing as
it's mostly absent from the second
teaser and well now we know the delay
footage also kicked off a rumor about
the possibility of new nintendo switch
hardware now i know switch pro has been
rumored over and over again throughout
the years but these were always separate
from breath while too at the very most
it would point to the game as the most
viable system seller but this time the
rumor is directly linked to the sequel
on april 4 2022 the folks at digital
foundry who specialize in gaming
technology and hardware claim that some
of the footage we've seen of the game is
almost certainly not running on native
hardware i'm not an expert on this stuff
but it's got something to do with the
shadows the resolution volume metrics
things of that nature something the bass
switch wouldn't be able to handle
according to them this reignited the
idea of breath2l2 launching alongside a
new top model switch now digital foundry
did mention that it's possible that the
footage was captured from an emulator of
sorts but they also pointed out that
this isn't something nintendo is known
to do so once again we'll just have to
wait and see on april 21 a new patent
was discovered which is also almost
certainly connected to breathtak 2. it
was filed by the technical director of
the game and its inventor ryuji
kobayashi is a zelda staff member as
well however it's not as exciting as the
patents i mentioned before some mistook
the information inside as an indication
that link's armor sets will have some
sort of new durability system in the
sequel but upon closer inspection this
is not the case in fact it has very
little to do with the gameplay
experience and is more of a quality of
life improvement for the developers
themselves from what i understand it's a
new coding method that makes armor and
clothing adjust automatically to fit any
character regardless of the difference
in body proportions this way the devs
don't have to create duplicate models
and adjust them manually to fit
different body shapes instead the vertex
points adjust themselves automatically
there's an article in the description
below that explains it a lot better so
go check it out if you're interested i'm
not going to be making a video about it
because like i said it's not all that
exciting it's also worth mentioning that
the application was done all the way
back in 2019 so it's actually much older
than the patents i mentioned previously
the only interesting thing i could see
coming from this is that it may hint to
the possibility of a playable zelda or
maybe even another character alongside
link after all the hero and princess
both have slightly different body
proportions so if both are playable they
might be able to swap armor sets but
let's not get too far ahead of ourselves
the final update on the game is an
actual leak the only legitimate leak so
far seeing as the whole spanish dub
thing ended up being a misunderstanding
it's fake phony fake so basically the
italian voice actor for daruk
accidentally slipped up on camera during
a conference of sorts he confirmed that
he would once again be voicing the rook
which is already pretty big since daruk
seems to pass on to the afterlife at the
end of the last game but on top of that
he also mentioned voicing a new
character supposedly a more serious
ancestor of daruk now i'm not going to
go further into it than that i've
already voiced my distaste about the way
this leak was handled i mean filming
someone in a vulnerable position like
this potentially ruining their career or
worse getting them sued for nda
violation just for a quick scoop
nah man not cool
not cool but hey i said i would include
every update and it's already out in the
open now anyway so do with that
information what you will and with that
we have covered the entire timeline of
breath 202's development so far what
happens next entirely depends on what
nintendo decides to do in the coming
weeks and months like i said i can't say
if the game will show up but it is that
time of year when the stars tend to
align for zelda fans i know it's
technically not an e3 presentation but
let's be fair ever since nintendo
switched to mostly digital only events
their e3 presentations have become
pretty much indistinguishable from their
general showcases in fact there's been
regular directs that are as long if not
longer than their e3 counterpart so
anything goes with nintendo you know and
hey i managed to get through the entire
thing without once mentioning the zona
ah damn it anyway thank you so much for
watching if there is a direct i will be
streaming the event right here on the
channel as per usual however if the game
shows up i won't stick around for very
long after the show is over and instead
i'll get straight to work on the
analysis a big thanks as always goes to
my mods in chat and on discord and my
generous patreons and channel members
who continue to make the channel
possible you continue to be amazing and
that is all for now this is dawn signing
off and have a good one
[Music]
you